today is going to be the best day ever I
love sunshine I love butterflies but
more than anything I love Doug hey
shut the up piece of
that's Doug the best owner in the world
we're playing this game called Fetch and
he drops me off really far
away and drives home without me when I
bring the ball back he says that's
how I know I won the game
hey honey you ever been with an Afghan
before I don't think so but thank you
thank you for me kid he left your ass oh
that can't be right you are officially
astray that would mean
duck doesn't love me
poor little guy I should probably talk
to him I am a therapy dog Fred you can
learn how beautiful it can be when
you're off the leash this beer is making
me dizzy he's about to get real Dizzy up
in this I'm having a great time
this right here make me a
little ass friend with the
home perm and what
did you just say I really hate for this
to get violent
he was straight you can do anything you
want I'm going back to Doug's what the
man he needs to pay for what he did
with the only thing he truly loves I'm
to bite his dick off oh wait did he just
say yeah I'm still a little drunk but I
said I'm gonna bite his dick off oh we
gon up
big day today you've ever humped
anything before I wouldn't say I've
humped or saved there you go red I'm
doing good tell him you're his daddy hey
gnome I'm your father it's good to
finally meet you right even under these
strange circumstances
we're completely lost and my little
puppy paw pads are really hurting right
now so how exactly could this get worse
oh my God holy
oh
guys we've got a dick to Ripper
what are those kind of looks like food
oh uh give me a second you look
different you look different too
how so is it my human hands